this one is interesting to me we have to
play this whole one through this is an
interesting um
i'll just let it roll
never walk alone at night don't forget
to cover your drink you can't go out
dressed like that men have urges
seriously they need to cover up
it distracts the boys
they can't control themselves be careful
watch out for boys boys only want one
thing men are like animals did i mention
you need to walk shout
hey hey hey chill chill chill
boys will be boys
i mean
i don't know why he would do a thing
like that
seems like a pretty stunned up guy to me
all right oh another lady folk being a
tad hysterical
they do that sometimes yeah
hey hey hey hey hey
not all men i don't really see this
inequality thing as a particularly
urgent issue so i think this doesn't
make it up to me because the initial
message i got out of it was that society
just confuses everyone i think everyone
who watches that one gets a little bit
of something different out of it but
society can be confusing right because
in one breath it's like mineral pigs you
know you have people that say
oh if you dress a certain way you're
inviting rape you remember that whole
discussion and again there's no nuance
in that debate so actually let's have
that conversation for a second because i
know that's controversial too
there's an extreme that's brought up all
the time when you say women if you dress
remember some guys would come out and
say if you dress like that you deserve
it
no
one no okay if you dress
super sexy [ __ ] you know and now it's
getting even worse year by year right
pretty soon it's going to be people in
the club just naked like just thong
underwear i mean it's like ridiculous if
you look from 15 years ago to now what's
happened it's just soon it's gonna be
like you know two of those you know
those little nipple covers that are
clear that and like a thong underwear
and that's going to be into a rave
in new york city yeah that's what that's
what it is
we're there but like in regular i'm
talking about people who go like out on
saturday night to a regular lounge or
bar not even a rave it's it's just less
and less women are just
the skirts are gay i mean it's really
unreal
people have daughters out there i don't
know man you guys must do something to
calm your some cbd or something in your
private time because i do not imagine
honestly i i really can't and in 10
years who knows and now with the selfies
and you never know oh terrible but
here's the thing
no are those people inviting danger to
their bodies are you saying like oh
there's an excuse for someone to rape a
woman no there is never an excuse to
inflict harm danger on another person
that's a crime okay so i don't care what
somebody does in terms of what they wear
or how they walk or what you think
they're inviting
that is not
a pass for you to inflict danger okay
they're not inviting danger simply by
dressing sexy but here's the caveat
what are they inviting
right what is going on there is there
not some accountability if that girl
dresses like a [ __ ] and i mean
completely you see what's going on now
i'm not talking about a sexy outfit i'm
talking about they walk and you can
literally see the cheeks coming out of
the bottom of the dress if you're
dressing like that to go out what is
your objective your attention seeking we
can all acknowledge that what kind of
attention are you looking for
what kind of attention you think you're
going to get you know
who what type of guy is going to come up
to you at the end of the night you know
what they're going to be looking for you
know all that you don't get to then get
mad oh i only have guys coming up to me
you want to sleep with me they don't
take me seriously if you're walking
around
like a poster girl for promiscuity right
that is a reality i'm not i'm not again
there is a distinction between someone
who dresses sexy who looks in the mirror
wants to look good feeling a sexy vibe
goes out that's not what i'm talking
about i'm talking about people you see
and you're like
oh wow like did they wear that out like
you you you pull to the side of the road
and say a small prayer for their parents
hoping they don't see it and just like
go bonkers
that's what i'm talking about and it's
becoming more and more commonplace so no
it's not an invitation for violence but
it's an invitation for something and you
have to be able to hold women
accountable
for something right you got to be
accountable for what you draw to you
right not danger not again not danger
but what kind of attention what are you
looking for at the end of the day what
do you expect somebody to glean from
that really just that you i mean do you
go to the library like that
would you walk into the library like
that would you walk into like what no
you're going into the club like that why
what are you looking for at the club
dressed like that tell me i would love
to girls out there if you're here on the
chat
or you know you want to message me on
any of my socials at any time if you
dress half naked you're proud of it
you're out there doing your thing
tell me why do you walk around living
room like that
do you i'm curious maybe you do maybe
it's all for you and you're looking in
the mirror i don't know but it seems
probably in many cases that that's not
what's happening
in the same breath those same ladies i'd
love to hear from you are you upset when
people make assumptions
because they're going to
what do you expect you see a guy walking
down the street no joke complete no top
no pants and he's got just a little
handkerchief covering the schlong okay
you see that just a little hank
and he's walking around the club with
g-string you're going to make an
assumption
you're going to go over to that guy and
you're going to say
you know i really want to i really want
to talk to you i really would love to
get out of here grab a cup of coffee
you're going to go over you're going to
be thinking you know what that guy
that you know christmas dinner with my
parents
that guy no you're not
just reverse it i always find it it's so
easy if you just reverse the rolls for a
second and put yourself in someone
else's shoes so i understand what she's
saying in the video that the messaging
can be confusing
but every single person needs to be
accountable for their behavior their
actions how they dress if you're looking
for that
if you're looking for that one night
stand and you're dressed like you want
that one night stand and you're putting
that out there do what you want you're a
grown adult
go right ahead
if you're not looking for that and
you're dressed like you're looking for
that and somebody assumes by nature of
what you're looking like that you're
looking for that don't be mad about it
be rational about it think about it say
well what message am i putting out there
you don't like the message you're
putting out there change it you can
still be sexy if you like the short clip
you can catch another one here or you
can catch the full episode right here
[Music]